[Music]
in today's eight on your side for the
next three days leading up to
thanksgiving we are going to be
discussing the black friday pitfalls to
avoid we connect with one expert who
reminds us to do our homework if we're
after those black friday doorbusters so
we can avoid lousy products and low
availability
andrea warwick has been covering black
friday deals for more than a decade a
nationally recognized consumer savings
expert who says some door buster deals
are made specifically for black friday
and they could be missing key components
or features clothing or home goods could
be made of cheaper material ultimately a
low price on a lousy product is never a
good deal so you just really want to do
your homework when you're shopping in
person touch the material of clothing
and home goods to make sure that it's of
high quality and then review the product
details to make sure it has the
components and features you want look at
the model number to find out if that's
the model that's been sold all year long
she adds retailers know they can get
shoppers through the door with really
low prices on those doorbusters but the
problem is shoppers go and they don't
realize the doorbuster deals are limited
in quantity here's the catch retailers
know that they can entice you to buy
things that maybe aren't marked down
that much so if you're planning to go to
a store to get your hands on that
doorbuster read the fine print figure
out how many are available if it's in
low quantity unless you're planning to
stand in line chances are you're not
going to get your hands on them and
you'd fare better to shop around online
to get a similar or same item for less
hassle